so wouldn't it be good if in every
society or every organization we had
some people who specialized in
specialized in saying hey what are the
opportunities and then we had other
people who specialized and saying well
but what are the risks and it just so
happens that a lot of people have
trouble doing all that in themselves
when we have systems that are well
constituted with people who have
different personalities and different
motives and goals we actually can get
better outcomes we can have a discussion
between them yeah well that's exactly
why that it's it's for that precise
reason that that I've been so interested
in free speech as a as a value because
well even on the economic front it's
pretty obvious if you look at things
economically that the entrepreneur types
who start businesses are lumped in with
the liberal creative types we've done a
lot of work on the prediction of
entrepreneurial behavior and ability and
its openness that's the big predictor
it's not the only one it's openness and
iq fundamentally but for managerial and
administrative expertise it's oh it's IQ
and conscientiousness so the Liberals
start businesses and and but they can't
run them because they're they're their
interests flipped and they don't have
the organizational ability and the
Conservatives can run them but they
can't continue to transform and expand
them it yin and yang yin and yang yep so
so one more thing about what happened in
Nazi Germany that that's very relevant
and interesting because it's it's useful
to get these motives right you know
first of all if if something disgusts
you if something if you're afraid of
something then you run away from it or
you freeze but if something disgusts you
you try to burn it or dig or kill it
right you try to get rid of it or expel
it that's that's right though you want
to get it away and destroy it
what so when Hitler first came to power
he put in a bunch of public health
schemes like he had vans that went
around and screen people for
tuberculosis then he went on a factory
cleanliness campaign so the factories
were supposed to be tidied up and he
washed he bathed about four times a day
by the way it was also a great
worshipper of willpower which is
associated with orderliness and seems
maybe to be associated with disgust
sensitivity in some way that isn't yet
understood yeah yeah I don't I don't
understand that connection either so
they he
Vence factory owners in Germany to get
rid of the rats in the might and mice
and the and the insects in the factories
and also to clean them up and beautify
them but the gas they used to clean up
the factories was Zyklon a and it was
the variation of that gas Cyclon B that
was then used in yeah so you could see
this ramping up date so it was yeah
absolutely so it was public health then
it was social cleanliness then he went
into the asylums and cleaned them up and
so it was just this expansion of of who
was contaminated and who was impure and
I think also his fascination with fire
and his use of fire symbolism was also
associated with that with that appeal to
purification because the whole idea of
purification by fire is a very ancient
idea